Patrick Wilson thank you very much I've
been looking for that kind of support
let me see the filthy room again huh
buddy how you doing sir
nice it's been a wild day and they've
been they've been making fun of me for
my beard it's we hate it it's very
Dreyfus of you actually thank you it is
yeah yeah that's true whose life is it
anyway he died paralyzed below the neck
[Laughter]
from context yeah yeah yeah really good
movie Patrick Wilson speaking of good
movies hey thanks I mean you know I've
been a fan of a lot of your movies we've
talked about a lot of them a few but oh
I was just moving over cuz you know Judy
go Karen Feehan hi what's over here with
us and of course you know Jim Norton yes
no Jim Norton but you're a big part of
your entering into superhero world I am
so I feel like yours re-entering right
but you're gonna be part of the DC
theoretical franchise now yes
theoretically theoretically which puts
you in the DC franchise and yes
the horror movie franchise yes that's
incredible for you both Warner Brothers
really it's a studio that I enjoy yeah
like that no not really
and well you know I think about in terms
of I guess job security right that yeah
or at least like okay if they if these
work then you do a few I'd love to get
into a superhero franchise especially
one that is gonna make more of ya kids
you know they're gonna do another one
it's making like 200 million overseas
that's crazy Aquaman yeah everybody's
saying really good things about it -
that's it do you read do you read that
stuff like the the advance reviews and
figuring out what it is really I mean
you know you get sent stuff it's hard
it's really hard to avoid yeah all that
yeah really but I don't like scour it
for we were just talking about a dealing
with Twitter and mentions and stuff like
that and Jim was saying that he deleted
it from his phone just because that's a
smart I still yeah at home like I still
like to
but on the phone it's just too and it's
not only for negative [ __ ] like how much
positive [ __ ] do I know how much
feedback do I need you almost want to
have a dummy Twitter account just so you
can have loads mind just so you can
follow accounts that you're actually
interested in and not have to deal with
anything else yeah because there are I
mean the bones of Twitter is good but I
guess you can't really avoid no it's
everything right - it's too difficult
and then people because people also just
send you a review like hey check this
out it says something great like alright
and then it says like one nice thing
right read reviews that's horrible I
always reveal you find it so when I show
it well when is I it's so hard if you're
doing theater because that's the worst
because you'll read it and then every
time you get to that part yeah on stage
you're thinking oh that [ __ ] [ __ ]
said this about me you know what I mean
I stood on stage but of course I mean
it's been social media wasn't around
when I was very pleased they already got
into this [ __ ] I've been called you know
you know was amazed II yeah I've got a
friend of mine that he nothing feels
super old but I was I was sitting there
we were talking about him doing a show
and he goes it's just so weird now as
opposed to like 90s and early aughts
when we were doing theater when he said
you know now we have to tell people not
even in the audience cast members
literally onstage in the wings with
phones and it's I can't yeah it's being
really ridiculous yeah I can't imagine
that I I feel so old
when's the last time you did theater I
mean a long run oh ten years ago maybe
yeah I mean I've done like you know I
did a week of a show last year and that
kind of thing when you're actually when
you're doing it though do you really
need to concentrate on every performance
you get to a place where it's such
muscle memory that you know I mean it's
it's clean it sounds to me like Dan's
focusing on your script
if you
masterful way yeah I mean that's the
part that would trip me out is that
they're not focusing on the play I feel
like if I saw a person that I was doing
a show with doing that I'd have no faith
in their ability to carry this with me
you know ya know it's again I couldn't I
just I mean it's two hours right you
can't just be in your your job doing
your being your character for two hours
that [ __ ] check-in your [ __ ] phone
seeing people in the audience have heard
to is have you stopped people I I do but
you can't do it in a theater like what
if you're you know no you have a script
you can't but I always say [ __ ] yeah you
hear what happened at the the opening of
the cher show with Kanye yeah yeah Kanye
was in the audience for opening night
and the next morning chair somebody yeah
one of the actors yeah tweet it out suck
Kanye saying that uh I know that you had
really important business on your phone
but a lot of us were distracted we're
trying to do a play on stage who is
saying that
sure no no the guy who was in the cher
show there's another show where someone
from the audience
they were wait you know is about ten to
eight right went on the stage on the set
and I got their phone in no yes yes yes
walked on the [ __ ] stage and plugged
their phone in where's security
where's like there's little pages or
stages okay you know what Kanye
responded the dynamics of Cher and
Sony's relationship made Kim hopefully
I'll ski the same way made Kim and I
grab each other's hand made Kim and I
grab each other's hand and saying I got
you babe please pardon my lack of
etiquette we have so much appreciation
for the energy you guys put into making
this masterpiece all right I got you
baby I got you babe what are the real
accent no you you did it wrong Jim yeah
I got you babe it's funny the major
question is
I was a kid I had a crush on Chaz Bono I
was in love with Chad I had no idea he
was chastity yeah yeah I loved her she
was adorable you all saw that turned out
yeah she was cute yeah I had such a
thing for her when I was a boy yeah but
you never had to deal with that so are
you you never I deal with cell phones on
stage because I guess maybe except for
the week run here and there whatever
no yeah no no nothing no one time there
was somebody that was just going crazy
in the audience and and I and I was
gonna stop but then I thought you know
what I'm gonna stop and yell at them and
then they're gonna end up being like
having an epileptic fit I'm gonna feel
really horrible I think gonna say great
my luck I would read him the riot act
think I've done something like yeah he's
actually you know special needs and then
I feel like they feel bad right I didn't
do anything crazy he'll just was a lot
of shouting there what it actually ended
up being was this old man being really
angry because somebody took his seat so
they're just already fighting they
probably couldn't hear each other
because we were talking yeah actually at
the risk of bringing up another Kanye
reference that's exactly what he did
when he was at his show and he was
telling everybody to stand down that's
right and he was like I'm not performing
this song I see you not standing I'm not
performing until you stand up and they
were like he's in a wheelchair
that's right so real born on the fourth
of July moment circa 90s when does Sonny
Bono die because you may be in a very
similar year he died in the 90s in the
skiing 93 yep yes aggressively tree
shopping later than expected that's more
topical than my room Springsteen the
other night and these people at the play
ah yeah and these people were making so
much noise all they got up there was
three of them they had the whole row how
to get up two rows in front of me they
walk out then they come back they're
standing on the side they're talking
they have a light they're looking for
something on the floor the usher comes
over and I said guys can you know
because you spent so much money on these
yeah how much I said like a normal price
okay but I said can you guys shut the
[ __ ] up and the usher came over because
I couldn't take it anymore
did you ever talk like that again and
this thing I'm take you out a and I'm
like excuse me I'm paid my money these
people won't shut up they're my
flashlight out there making everyone
stand up right curse yeah I know I said
I'm agreeing with them you shouldn't be
cursing no but you matter what I care
what you're agreeing okay I mean at some
point you just can't it's just yeah make
everyone in the row get up so you can
walk out and then start making noise and
have a flow and then they went back in
and back out again it's like I say in my
book the death of courtesy know exactly
what people are thinking in these
moments people do stink though I made
you know it's amazing the rage that
builds up it happens to me in movie
theaters all the time when you go I'm
sure they're gonna turn their phone off
it's not a big deal like the light is
just on I'm sure it's not gonna stay and
then you can just feel it bubbling
you're bubbling and you're like they
have to stop I'm gonna I'm gonna do
something's gonna happen yeah I was
during an argument right yes yeah a
young guy and an old guy and the old guy
who's popcorn like it was like an ex-cop
or something and just the wrong guy to
[ __ ] with yeah
yeah be careful of physical
confrontations yeah but you never know
that's yeah well now and especially with
guns like if I'm driving I have terrible
road rage I know that Chuck but you know
it's like you just don't you don't know
what's good people are enraged not worth
it
no to keep moving and I'm just I'm not
really you know I'm not violent I just
you know you do you pull up to them and
you roll down your window and you go yay
that was my fault
[Laughter]
I just smile just get so angry don't
[ __ ] around driving and there was two
lanes so I was jumping into the right
lane to make the right and the guy in
front of me did that thing where he
moved in and wouldn't let me pass and
I'm really I was in such an absolute
rage and I realized it was the shoulder
and everyone was going into that lane so
he was just blocking me from cutting
people off which he was right to do and
then I start like talking in my car
alone I'm like all right dude I didn't
know I didn't know I'm sorry I was right
but I was wrong dick yeah terrible story
but just my only traffic story from
recent years well just lets people know
that you're bad person yeah and I Drive
in Texas and you go to visit different
state colleges sort of attack harass me
on the subway last week why I went in
and I you know I was holding on to the
pole you know you're sitting down he's
like can you not lean on me lean on 800
times a day I was on the way he's like
well I'll get up and you could sit down
and he gets up and I don't go to sit
down no no he was nasty why did I just
get up so you're not leaning on me and
he gets up and he stands next to me and
just won't stop just won't oh yeah oh
yeah you just need to and and this woman
behind me is like don't let him ruin
your day done but he I said shut this I
like finally
doing yeah I did I said [ __ ] is your
problem seriously shut just shut up and
what did he do and he's like oh you're
so oh you're nobody you're nobody just
rude
he went stopped and then he turned out
of ponytail he was so unattractive he
had a ponytail
how old do you think forties oh yeah
that guy's just been dumped yeah finally
happened that guy with the pointed what
he turned he turned his back to me so go
you can look at this and I said oh your
head without a brain I don't know he
that people were I said that good no no
I said you're [ __ ] such an old white
man do you think that maybe if you stop
cursing so much I am from New Jersey
what County Essex oh okay I was I grew
up in New York runs work
no I County did you count I didn't know
that yeah and then I met Rutgers did you
yeah it'll set Douglas I'm sure no I did
not go to Douglass uh-huh
you know what Mason Gross was just
joining her I was a music major
yeah I had my classes over there but I
didn't I got sober to cook college you
did not I did I used to go to meetings
are all the time congratulations thank
you very much I owe a great affinity for
Rutgers beautiful you're killing it well
I can't take a [ __ ] nice boring
stroll
[Laughter]
on the 4th of July yeah yeah Texas
stories really nothing wrong with that
do you uh do you do you feel like acting
in movies like this especially Aquaman I
have this theory about Hugh Jackman
because I watched him I watched him on
The Today Show and and he was performing
songs from I claim is and stuff like
that and he's young amazing like yeah
yeah of all the Wolverine movies
laymen's is still my favorite real
Jackman thing ever I love it and I'm
sitting there going like I figured you
out Jackman you were just doing all
those Wolverine movies so you can get
away from him and do whatever you want
for the rest of your life sure and you
can go now perform and do theater and
and do what you want it's what he loves
to do is that in your mind at all at an
amazing talent he's unbelievable because
you're amazing - well thank you you know
people said some people and I've talked
to you about it before some people don't
even realize that you sing some people
don't realize you're a theatre I do you
sing and I feel like of the Opera right
yeah I feel like you hired that talent I
would want to make sure you said like to
say that cast albumin dry what is it
yeah that was great
what is Brigadier yeah yeah it's like an
old-timey musical written by Lerner and
Loewe who do you play in it like a
person he's a good guy they're two guys
that go to get lost in Scotland it's a
super super old it's awesome almost
being almost like being in love as much
okay anyway is that is that in your head
right cars not that kind of thing right
yeah I'm not a I'm not a go out there do
like a one-man show kind of guy yeah
that's not really my my vite have you
thought if i can get a couple superhero
movies a couple more horror movies under
my belt oh yeah no no just your theater
for the rest of my life yeah I mean I
don't worry about anything yeah I know
you can do theater for the rest of my
life I love theater I'm trying to do a
show next year that I'm not I'm planning
on doing so in New York yeah yeah at the
public so that that'll probably you've
never worked there I did Shakespeare in
the Park and there
what's so amazing yeah I've never done
that either yeah I mean I would I would
love to do that would you put your in
with them would you play yeah I don't
want to get abused as a Montague right I
was in the all-female Taming of the
Shrew
that's like grêmio solid I've never read
Taming of the Shrew no it's perfect yeah
women hating yeah they're gonna do Sam
I don't hate women how dare you how dare
you I was Bianca yeah I'm an alto okay
just me Kate coming back that's cool
with Kelly O'Hara who was in Brigid yeah
man with me I'll bring it back wow she's
amazing too
she's awesome yeah yeah she's about the
best thing my theater actors especially
musical theater actors they're they're
the most disciplined I mean I mean it's
it's an another whole level of
commitment and it's it's a it's amazing
have to sing I saw a book of Mormon
three times it was incredible oh they
don't like musicals but it was just
incredible
yeah I like they had to be lip-synching
but they weren't like that's real have
you seen have you seen Aquaman I've seen
it yes several times do you like do you
usually do that this for me I got two
boys a nine year old 12 so I finally
done a movie that they can dig and that
was part of the reason that I really was
like all right let's do this be great is
there an actual fit so young to have
kids that age
[Laughter]
I do a little flunk oh the action
figures are cool but now that we got the
little Funko pop what's your name in it
or we look up our master ocean master
figure he's pretty he's pretty good your
first action figure no but my first one
I think that people might may buy four
Watchmen I had one actually strangely
had one there I am right there actually
had one for randomly for the 18 no one
cared that's cool yeah it's got a cool
mask yeah it's it's awesome it's you
know look it's super fun it's a good
it's uh it's kind of interesting to see
how it's translated from it was a big
gamble opening in China and all those
places but yeah why do you do that I
think they they I don't know China
there's more people there no I mean it
was a big gamble I think they just
thought it would do well there I I even
though a lot of other superhero movies
don't do great but I think come the the
storyline for them the visuals it's it's
it's a because so much of its underwater
yes the VFX are crazy I'm sure they've
done research too long and maybe that
character is popular in Asia yeah yeah
and and so it did huge over there so
we've already we haven't even opened
your nards so do you get like checks
just from the action for your like it's
everything completely separate keep the
money pretty much yeah you given you
don't know like royalties for that but
it's you're like this yeah well that's I
guess part of the deal when you sign up
you give it away Judy give it away they
own the character you give it away yeah
yeah they own the character do you have
any right so you don't really have much
of an idea of what the film is actually
gonna look like while you're shooting
not all mice I mean most of my movie is
underwater so we and and we have called
your breath a lot no not at all I was
never in the water but because when
you're totally submerged you don't look
wet right so we shot it all in green
screen right but did you and you did
this kind of like moving in
early like you you're swimming you felt
like we were some strange avant-garde
theater did you have to hang around did
they have like a you know I chose I've
done they bring like a court quote
unquote choreographer but like they
really know about body movement stuff
like that we do and we not for that kind
of slack we got sort of lucky probably
back to my musical theater training uh
literally me and willem dafoe would we
do a lot of that sort of swimming around
acting right like and he supposedly has
the hugest penises I've heard he has a
big dick is it true I've never honestly
I would tell you oh I've heard that I've
never heard yeah yeah I actually ever
had to I wouldn't assume that you knew
because you did oh yeah they're
underwater and tights and how do you not
see it I heard why heard also James
Woods yeah really
that makes me sad yeah oh really I mean
I wouldn't I wouldn't remember the
Milton Berle stuff but I'll take it word
for it ask a question about the Aquaman
I don't remember what it was that we're
talking good good job it's always
important when you forget your question
acknowledge it my mother always said
when they're not paying attention
interjected no I had something that we
were going to hear talk about being
underwater all the time in the green
screen I just forgot it I am very happy
especially for your sake that they made
Aquaman cool because for a long time
like Aquaman in the traditional the
orange shirt the blond hair was it yeah
it was it was a little silly and but I
think that's I think you can that's
that's ex Niner he cast Jason he just
was like you know what we got to go the
way other way you get to keep the
Trident that's a question it's hard to
get through
I asked you kept the mask I do have mass
I have gloves kept some gloves do you
care stuff usually or did you just
because this is a superhero - it's one
thing if I can yeah yeah what did you
keep from the from the James Bond movies
lanterns I don't know oh just like
little cities yeah yeah what did you
keep him insidious yeah I kept lit
little interest that's the same ring
country I don't know I forgot you were
in that that's [ __ ] the same cross
I've worn in that movie I've worn it in
two other movies - oh really yeah play a
Christian yeah I wear that same cross
you've been into really hardly the
inserts insidious I loved was very scary
and in that confident terrifying
contract it was great yes
yeah the the lady who jumped off the top
of the bureau did you get to know her
him yeah I've made that no that's Joe
Bashar it's crazy that's Joe Bashara
who's our composer so it's basically
like John Williams playing Darth Vader's
which is awesome as if the conjuring
universe continues and you know the non
just came out and everything yeah you
sit there going like can you throw me a
bone here we there's enough bones thrown
we threw we were in we're in Annabelle 3
oh really
and where we start conjuring three okay
so it still happening so that's why my
goal see so if I do a couple those
couple that's what you do movies then
you know then I can do theater when I
want not the rest of my life right why
don't ya that's you figured it out
that's the goal the DC franchise that's
what I want the conference that way you
want what stand up Jim no
we've done the neverland special